right now none other than the lead
analyst for CBS from Detroit getting
ready for the Vikings and the lions game
on thanksgiving day Phil Simms join us
big Phil how you doing bomb dome well
how about you I'm just look man some yes
mr. cutter Adam GaSe both coming on the
show I love it no pressure for you buddy
yeah a little bit yeah a little pressure
yeah that's right I'm not on a winning
streak like those guys are so but you
know good for them you know Dirk is um
I've known him a long time and the sea
Tampa Bay turn it around how they have
the last couple weeks and Adam GaSe um I
always told people don't be fooled about
how he looks he's a tough guy right you
look Amy's young and all that you know
he can lay the law down when it comes to
talking to players everything and they
they've responded very well done in
Miami so who's the least tough-looking
NFL coach Polly stop looking in FL coach
I don't know if I'll quite get into that
all right we will do a 180 back into
football here and just before the break
and before we talk about your game
coming up tomorrow between the lines and
the Vikings the guys were asking me to
put my quarterback lens back on and
think about this question I asked it to
you if you were a quarterback in the NFL
right now would you rather habs ich
elliott dez bryant start a team that way
or the entire cowboys offensive line
Cowboys offensive line not even so it
evens up there I I would just look I
dented dallas cowboy game this year
against the cincinnati bengals whoever
pretty good defensive front so i
probably watched at least half of their
games all their games on TV but half of
them on you know coaches tape or
whatever and it's one of those things
once you get done watching you go wow I
don't know if I it people are going to
want to hear me talk on TV so much about
an offensive line but to me when I was
getting ready for the game I said this
is the story and I just remember going
the center Travis Frederick and Zack
Martin a right guard I'm thinking I've
never seen two guys dominate the line of
scrimmage and do the things they were
doing on offensive line
and and along i'm not gonna say ever but
a long long time in there it's it's it's
incredible and the cowboys you know i
talked to a lot of new coaches around
the league and general managers and they
all say the same thing a lot of not all
but most kind of bring up the dallas
cowboys and it's always we want to build
the team from inside out because getting
that offensive line straight and your
defensive line straight are the two
hardest things to do and there's one
thing Paul that you cannot overcome in
the NFL and that's an average offensive
line because every week is just you know
what are we going to do what can we
count on we can't count on getting time
for the quarterback so what plays do you
draw up well you got to be careful now
you can't drive the ball down the field
it just goes on and on and every time
you look up its third and eighth what's
in the NFL is just it's impossible now
to hold some of these pass rushers out
and obvious long passing situations yeah
now knowing how strongly you feel about
the offensive line is it lessen the
credit that you give to dak Prescott um
no no it doesn't and and mainly the
forget that he's a rookie if he was a
veteran quarterback if Tony Romo was
back there having a great year and doing
my dad Prescott is doing I wouldn't
lesson what he was accomplishing so why
should we do it to a rookie quarterback
let's give credit to it that that how
hard it is and how much he has to learn
and all the other things that go along
with being a quarterback and I will say
this you know we didn't get a chance to
talk as much as usual about quarterbacks
turn the off season but dak Prescott Dan
Mullen the coach at Mississippi State
really runs a pro office they do all the
concepts they got everything going on
there during the shotgun a lot of course
but when I watched him you know he was
playing NFL football down there
Mississippi State and he got hit believe
me he got hit much more his senior year
Mississippi State and he's going to get
hit this whole year in the NFL and I
actually said it to him when I saw him
he just kind of laughed he goes well you
could say that I'm not going to say that
you know whatever but it was true he
play
under such pressure and still performed
well and the thing that jumped out about
him two things you know he had
experienced big school great competition
he played against and all that but the
size you know just look at him you don't
like a Mack truck yeah and you know that
that that's something you can count on
his mobility and his size are two things
that you know right you can count on him
as a quarterback and now the throwing
been pretty good too Paul burmeister
sitting in for dan Patrick talking to
Phil Simms of CBS Phil will call the
Vikings and the Lions tomorrow you talk
about that dress got see glasses on like
Dan Patrick where's I couldn't find them
on the desk here Phil no designer wear
you know they all about five prob about
five hundred and fifty dollars a pair
Johnny have those ok jacket issued by
NBC SN is all oh ok you mentioned how
big dak dak Prescott is I remember
talking to you about Andrew Luck when he
came out in the draft and you you kept
coming back to how big he was and that's
something like you just said that you
can count on now Andrew Luck may or may
not play tomorrow night against the
steelers he's in concussion protocol
we'll find out I guess a game time if
he's out there it can write a
conversation between the danettes and
myself about hiding injuries and how
players do it now and how would you do
it with an injury like that did you ever
find yourself in a situation when you
were playing for Bill Parcells in the
Giants where you had to or tried to hide
this kind of injury well it was a
different error and um you know just a
different time we were not talking about
concussions back any of those years 80s
and 90s and even in the late seventies
it was not talked about and you know it
was like all you got a headache tell you
you can't play with a headache you big
baby or you know this that and and I
don't ever I really don't ever remember
a player being held out of a game or not
playing because right I i can remember
guys being diagnosed with discussion a
concussion it wasn't it up so so you
know so I I would say this no I never
had an injury it didn't matter and you
know I broke my hand one time first game
of the year it was my left hand and they
looked at me said yeah your hands broke
the air
oh my gosh and then they looked at me go
your hands down bro and I said but you
just told me as well because no you
understand what we're saying your hands
not broke don't hear another word about
it that's it your hands are broke well
okay and I don't see any bandages on it
I don't want see it taped up and I don't
want to hear word about it right okay
and that was in that story so there you
go back in yeah I there you go you just
that's the way you play you know and not
that it's changed much something like
that you still play with nowadays that's
not a big deal but the China had a
concussion pretty hard to do and
especially I saw they hit that cause it
with a android lock in and the symptoms
down I don't know what it is but the
symptoms and these concussions I don't
know why it's gotten worse I know the
game is faster and all that but it seems
like so many of them comp all from what
from the quarterback or the player
falling in their head hitting the ground
surface that's where it seems to see a
lot of those I just go and I played on
astroturf and it I don't know it just it
seems to cause a lot more concussions
that we had to pass yeah teams were
playing on natural grass you wonder if
we would have as much of this right now
well that's a good discussion you know
in this modern day and age and and you
know a lot of people get mad because
they you know they they run this field
turf company or whatever the turf is
called down days but I'm natural grass
you know it you played college football
when that game I say it two players all
the time and they say when they play on
that sawgrass the game is over their
aches and pain better or not even get
percent of what they would be if you
play on artificial turf Paul burmeister
sitting in for Dan here this morning
talking to CBS lead analyst Phil Simms
let's get into a couple the games
tomorrow how do the Redskins find a way
to beat the cowboys ville well they're
not to deal with their offense of course
that said that that's very evident um
how about our boy Kirk Cousins man you
talk man quarterback that's letting it
go he what should go he sees it believes
it and throws it like he knows he's
going to put it right down the middle of
the plate and his control the football
has been fantastic he's now playing into
quite a while this year
playing like he did at the end of last
year just just it was awesome and his
accuracy the other night on the deep
balls was traumatic yeah and they're fun
to watch his style play Jay Gruden's
play-calling you know Jay Gruden's an
old but be careful here he's a just an
old bitter ex quarterback you know he
puts a lot of pressure on the
quarterback expects them to do well
because that's how he played he's tough
and did all that and you know you had
great success being a college
quarterback and and even in the Arena
League or whatever so a lot of that
Washington has to be Dallas Dallas's
weak spot is their defense the question
is you get enough chances at their
defense as for your game though Phil
you're in Detroit Lions Vikings finish
the sentence here for me the Lions have
won five of their last six games Phil
because what Matt Stafford and baby is
he that well it always not look at the
MVP because his numbers are not going to
match some of these other guys but what
he is doing it used to be just about med
stafford and the great throws down the
field of calvin johnson you know Paul
now it's real you know it's kind of fun
i'm sure it's fun for me even told me
this yesterday he has to go out there
and physically do it but now he's got to
play this working man's game because
they don't he doesn't get great
protection you know they can't run the
ball at all so he's got to play a
different position than he's ever really
played in the NFL and he's doing it he's
been is tremendous at it and then when
you put him in situations where he has
to make a great throw you know it I know
it you can do I don't know if the the
public knows it but he is an
unbelievable thrower of the ball and I
mean he can do it sideways over the top
anywhere you wanted and when you give
him those opportunities Minnesota
Vikings he makes that last Drive they
kicked along you'll know they beat them
well they made a great mistake which you
can't do against good quarterbacks in
the NFL a big situation they rush three
they gave him extra time and he drove
about a 30 yard in cut down the field
and you could even see it on the family
through it so hard so in that and that
won the game for rights to put him in
position to win so it is about Matt
Stafford when you talk about the Detroit
Lions this doesn't mean he
the best quarterback in the NFL Phil but
listen to you describe him the ways
throne is he the most gifted when it
comes to just naturally raw throw the
football I would put him in ear rogers
in the same class uh you know we always
get lost on air Rogers because he's a
little different they've been winning
more he's won a Super Bowl uh he
probably can get rid of it may be a
little quicker but to think about Matt
Stafford he's got all the throws all the
angles can and he's running around a lot
morning ever did in the past which is
really good um and it's just it's people
just don't pay attention and he is truly
like I said [ __ ] tomorrow we'll make
a little package of all the sidearm
throws you know throw him with people
ought to me throws around them whatever
it is he can do that and and he's
matured he truly is the leader the team
and it's really been fun to watch and
it'll just be interesting to see if they
can get their team you know they can
catch fire in other words can can the
defense live up to what I thought it was
going to be when the season started
right now they got good corners can the
defensive fronts start doing what
they're supposed to do and that's mean
what I mean by that is pressuring the
quarterback more because I know the
quarterbacks kind of hold his end up
that's for sure Phil Simms lead analysts
for CBS the NFL on CBS will be on the
call for Vikings and the Lions tomorrow
Phil happy thanksgiving buddy and thanks
for spending time with us all right I
got one question for you do you feel
smarter since you're sitting in dancers
here I'll answer that I feel the
pressure Phil I gotta be honest ah
there's no pressure are you kidding me
Lana there's no such thing as pressure
you know what you just gotta go out
there you can't beat Paul your next
quarterback you cannot be afraid of
thrown a couple intercepts and come on
just let it go I didn't say I was afraid
Phil come on I said it feel the pressure
and I'm gonna keep looking for those
glasses that might actually make me look
smarter okay oh there you go I look
great talking to you Paul see you down
the road Phil thanks Pete I'm always
good son ok but the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
you